Right now. All right, hello everybody. It is the 23rd of May and we're going to do our zoom call
for the night. So this is a nice slide. I like this. Change your mind and change your life. Well,
there's a lot of truth to that. It's not perfect tourism, but it does make a lot of sense.
What we think about what we put our mind to and what we allow in our mind
does affect our life tremendously. So it doesn't mean that we could just change our mind. And if
we're not going to have cancer anymore, it's instantly disappeared. We don't have headaches
anymore. Our headaches are gone or anything is a tear like that. But we do have to decide
and it's probably maybe the only thing that you have complete control of in your life is what you
put your mind on. And so I would highly recommend that you try to put your mind on things above.
Your blessings, your gratefulness of everything that you have in life and everything that exists
and the greatest to that, hopefully, is your relationship with your Savior. And there's a lot to be
thankful for. So with that, we're going to jump in into questions. We've got some heavy ones here.
Not quite the heaviest one, but it gets deeper. I went to the chiropractor for the adjustment,
as you said, because I do believe in chiropractic care. And my C3, that's your third cervical
vertebrae in your neck, was out. Now, he has me coming back three to four every three to four days.
I am truly hyped out around C3 to C1 to C3. I don't know what that means.
Maybe they have a rash. Maybe they feel irritated around that area, along with T5.
My immune system doesn't like the applicator tips. I'm assuming that's the tips that the chiropractor is
using for adjustments and that positive. The chiropractor suspects neuropathy. How do you determine if all
the treatments they suggest are necessary? I told them I need a break to let the sore inflamed area
settle down a little bit. Do you have any suggestions if any of the rife or secrets programs will help?
A lot of questions there. So, remember what if you have some inflammation? Definitely do the rife
programs. I would do accelerated healing on the rife. Do any of your sequence programs would be
helpful for this. So, I would say absolutely. If you have inflammation there due to what the
chiropractor is doing, I would honestly suggest maybe looking at a different chiropractor possibly.
Yes, I do believe that when you start making changes to your spine and there might even be good
changes, adjustments that it could be more sore to begin with than in order to heal. And get it back
to the first question. How he has become back every three to four days? How do I know if that's too much?
How do I know? Well, that's a tough decision. So, a lot of chiroprctors practice different ways.
That's the pro and cognitive chiropractic. There's some that practice on a basis of what's called
straight chiropractic and they just believe in the chiropractic philosophy of getting adjusted on a
regular basis is good for you. I tend to fall into that category. There's other chiroprctors that
practice corrective chiropractic and there's a time that I practice that way and those are the people
that are taking x-rays, very specific x-rays and then they're working along the process of changing
those x-rays and being able to take after x-rays to show that there's a change in that tone in what
they've done. So, I don't believe that's the chiropractor you went to. I believe that the way it
sounds like you were to this question, they don't have any objective data that is proving that you
need to come back or not. They're just saying that this was really out. They've palpated that and you
need to come back. If what he or she is doing isn't making you feel better, then maybe that's not
the place to go. Again, I know that sometimes when you first start getting adjusted, it doesn't
feel better to begin with, but after a number of treatments, you better improve, your symptoms
better improve or you want to go to somebody who is maybe more specific in their technique.
While I never want to bash another doctor or say anything ill about another doctor, I think it's
wise to make sure that you're getting the best care that you possibly can. If you don't feel like
you're getting good care for me, you should confront me about that as well, just like you should confront
any doctor. Question came through with the chat, are you okay with getting x-rays at a chiropractor?
I would say yes, I would be okay with getting x-rays, matter of fact, by okay, one x-ray
of the cervical, AP and lateral x-ray. That's two x-rays of your cervical spine.
In my mind, that would be extremely wise, because you got somebody that's adjusting your spine.
I used to take x-rays when I did chiropractic and I
found things on an x-ray that made me not want to adjust their spine. One time there was a
fracture of a vertebrae that I picked up on the x-ray and if I would have adjusted that person,
you could have injured that person severely. Especially if you have a history of cancer, you should
be going to a chiropractor that's either adjusting you with a very low, low, low force technique where
there is absolutely no possible fracture that could be ensued in that type of technique, or they better
taking x-ray of your spine to make sure that you don't have any, you know, God forbid, metastasis
to your spine, and that's what's causing the pain there, and then they adjust it and they actually
fracture the vertebrae. So, yes, I think it is a very good idea to take an x-ray,
give it any cancer history. There's no way when I practice chiropractic that I would take on
a cancer patient for chiropractic care without seeing full-side x-rays so that I make sure that they
don't have metastasis. That's just not very dangerous. So, you should have that. Now, if they're just
doing an activator technique or something like that, you could still hurt somebody with that, so you've
got to be really careful. Next question. Upon reading some of the rife programs, I read a call
across Adeto virus conjunctivitis and caker sores. It stated that call sores or caker sores are one
of the main causes of Alzheimer's. Is that true? I would say there isn't evidence that that's true,
but there is belief that Alzheimer's can be that herbiviruses can be a contributor to some Alzheimer's
events, but I would not say it's a main cause of Alzheimer's. It's said to alkalize the body,
use lizine, vitamin D, and curcumin, which latch onto plaque formation. So, alkalizing the body
is important because remember, we had a zoom call a few weeks ago. It's back that spoke about cold
sores and what cold sores are. Cold sores are herpes virus that lives in the nerve ganglion.
So, nerve ganglion is a nerve bundle. So, if you're at call sores and you're bound with,
it's usually in the trigeminal ganglion that's up in your upper cheek, and it lives there, and it's
really hard to kill. Even if you ran the herpes program all the time with the rife, you're never
going to completely kill that the herpes virus. It's probably going to be with you the rest of your life.
And it comes out when there's a change in pH. So, that's why when you lay in the sun for the first time,
that changes the pH of your mouth. You could get call sores or you suck on a lemon. That's very
acidic. You could, it changes the pH of your mouth and you could get call sores. Well, did the lemon
cause the call sores? Did the sun cause the call sores? Am I allergic to the sun? Do I have an
allergy to lemons or limes? No, you don't. It's just the pH change in the saliva that allowed the
opportunistic organism, the herpes virus, to travel down the nerve and to expose itself with an
inflammatory postural of your lip. So, changing the health, alkalizing the mouth. And I said that
in that previous zoom call, by even taking a calcium tablet, linking it to dabbing the calcium
tablet on the herpes. Call sores can be helpful. So, chewing up a calcium tablet, I'll gross that
might be in a taste like chalk, but that can help instantly change the pH of the mouth. Through the
mineral content in there, or any other mineral will help with that too. Lysine is a good amino acid
for decreasing call sores, especially people have chronic call sores. Environment D is very important
too because that helps the absorption and cell function of calcium and helps with mineralization. So,
that's really good too. You can certainly follow the rest of the instructions on this as well as
running the herpes programs itself. The other part of this person's question was, upon awakened as
when I get small blisters appear on the inside of my mouth, is it possible I become more acidic overnight?
Yes, it is very possible and one thing that might help that is literally opening up
one of your mineral capsules, dumping it in a little cup and dabbing your figure, wetting your figure
dabbing it in there and just kind of sucking on that a little bit, especially before you go to bed,
to help decrease the or increase the pH of your mouth before you go to bed so that might prevent that.
Next question is referring to some video that this person watched, this doctor of the video said
something about loading up with antioxidants while doing chemotherapy so that the chemo will target more
of the cancer cell and the antioxidants will protect the healthy cells. So, I know you recommend
water fast but I wonder what you think about that. It seems to make sense to me to load up with
antioxidants right before chemo like doing a very smoothie or something like that.
That's a very good question so that here's why it's a really good question so I put together a
couple pictures that I just pulled off the internet a couple of days ago and to understand the
answer to this question you have to understand a few things about what chemotherapy is doing to a person's
body purposely. So, first of all, we have to understand how cells die. So, here's a healthy cell,
a nice happy cell here, a smiling big mouth open there. These are actually parts of the cell but
cell dies through three main processes. What is normal programmed cell death? That's called apoptosis.
That's what's not taking place with a cancer cell. So, normally cells are supposed to live a certain
period of time. And then on the outside of the cell membranes things attach to it, stimulate a
process that goes inside on inside the cell that stimulates this normal programmed cell death,
this apoptosis. These particles of the cell break off and the cell gets partially really recycled.
So, that's a normal program that takes place in the cell where that cell is ready to die.
Cell death is actually a beautiful thing and your body reuses a lot of parts of that cell.
And there is in this process, there is no waste, there's no
hoaxibar reaction by the patient. You're not toxifying your body with cell particles because your body
is reusing these pieces and it's cleaning it all up. The other type of cell death is called
pathophagy. And we've spoken a lot about pathophagy. We've spoken a lot about apoptosis. So, this is how
your body cleans up things in the cell. Inside the cell itself and the cells themselves. It cleans
things up. This is how you clean up dead tissue. The third type of cell death is an abnormal type of
cell death. It's called necrosis. Necrosis is when cells die due to be poison. So, if you consume the
deadly toxin and you died from that deadly toxin, it was because too many cells went through the
necrosis and that's what killed you. So, the deadly toxin caused necrosis or lysis of the cell. So,
a necrotic cell dies through the process of lysis. So, cell lysis is when the cell literally explodes
due to a toxin and it can make you sick. So, for instance, a necrotic process that doesn't kill you
could be, let's say I cut my skin really bad. And I wound up and it forms a scar and a wound
and then that wound falls off right after a period of time. That's necrotic tissue. It died
through cell lysis through an abnormal doc through apoptosis, doc through autophagy, but through lysis.
The other example would be I got strep throat and my throat is super sore and I'm copied and I
had this really bad pain. I had a ton of cells die in my throat through the process of necrosis,
through bacteria killing cells. But it didn't kill me. My body eventually overcame that, killed the
bacteria and my body created new cells to lie by esophagus and I can speak again and I don't ever
sore throat anymore. But that's the process of lysis. Through the crosis, that's an abnormal or pathological
cell death. When you do chemotherapy, this is what's taking place. So, chemotherapy is causing lysis
and necrosis. So, even if the chemotherapy only killed the cancer cells, you still would get sick
from chemotherapy. Because if when the chemotherapy kills the cancer cells, all these dead particles
because the cancer cells basically exploding, that's causing all these particles from that cell
to be dispersed into the tissue that's picked up by the lips that's dumped into the blood that's
causing it overwhelmed with the liver and you feel sick. So, this necrosis or lysis of a cell,
this pathological death of a cell because of a strong drug given to the patient called chemotherapy
that is a poison, hopefully only uptaken by cancer cells but we know that's not necessarily true
is killing those cells. Well, we wanted to kill the cancer cells. I don't mind being sick
from the cancer cells dying and honestly, I don't mind my patients being sick from the cancer
cells dying. Hey, we could overcome that sickness, but the problem is the cancer cells are not the only
thing that is killed through necrosis or lysis when we take a strong poison like chemo. But this doctor
is saying we should take an antioxidant to protect the healthy cells. Well, I see one ginormous problem
with that. So, now we have to understand the difference between oxidation in my cell prooxidants
and antioxidants. Well, shouldn't I always be taking a ton of antioxidants? Wouldn't that be good for me?
Yes, no. So, we need this struggle between prooxidation and antioxidation. We need to have a struggle
here. This is the balance in life. Remember, I've said numerous times that there isn't anything
that goes on in your body that is necessarily all bad. Then there isn't anything that goes on in
your body that's necessarily all good. It's about a balance. You have oxidating processes that take
place inside your cells and then those are balanced out by antioxidating processes that are taking place
inside the cell so that you don't ever have too much of this or too much of this because you need some
oxidation that goes on inside the cell and you need antioxidation that goes inside the cell.
Now, chemotherapy is a prooxidant. That's what makes it a poison and that's what makes it effective
against a cell. So, prooxidants are going to kill cells. So, let me show you this slide.
So, for those of you that we've done your genetics already, you may have seen this. If you haven't
watched any of my genetic videos, I'd suggest you do so because I go over this adenosium.
This here is your transulfuration pathway. The purpose of this pathway is numerous, but one of the major
purposes of this pathway is to make glutathione, which is a cellular antioxidant that works inside the
cell as an antioxidant. So, here's the detox pathways right here that are making these antioxidants
in a person's cells. If I have defects along any of these genes, that's why we need to look at these
genes. We're not going to make a lot of glutathione. We're not going to get rid of oxidants.
So, one of the major oxidants that are that are in our body, they are what are called free radical.
Or reactive oxygen species and reactive nitrogen species. So, ROS and RNS. So, these reactive
oxygen and reactive nitrogen species or these free radicals damage cells and they can cause what?
Lysis or necrosis. They can cause cancer. Well, we don't want those. We want to get rid of those then.
Well, that is true, but in the wisdom of your body, you actually make some oxidant species. You make
superoxanion and you make peroxinitrate. What's the purpose of that? It's so dangerous. Why would we make
that? Why is infinite wisdom created that we actually create superoxide and peroxiditrate in our
body? Because it actually has a purpose, too. So, superoxide and peroxiditrate are free radicals.
That means they have an extra electron open on the compound. So, they will attach. They are
attracted to attach to things. If they attach, if we have excess amounts of them, they can attach to
our cells and they can damage our cells and they can cause heart disease, they can cause cancer,
they can cause all sorts of bad things because they cause oxidative damage, cell and tissue damage,
and we can get cancer and all sorts of diseases from it. But we make it. Why would we make it? Because
they also could attach to bacteria and viruses and things that are in our body constantly
to keep the balance of those things down. So, we don't want to have none of these,
but we don't want to have excess these. It's about balance. So, how do we know we have too many of these?
Well, we could discern if I have a disease that is caused by oxidative stress,
pretty good chance I might. Well, what are those? Heart disease,
corduary artery disease, arteriosclerosis, cancer? We could go on. Do you have those disease? Well,
we should probably check. Do we have high amounts of this? Well, one other way to check is let's
look at your genes. If I have a bunch of defects on this gene right here, the SOD gene,
this SOD gene makes superoxide disretais. It makes superoxide disretais for the purpose of
getting rid of superoxide and peroxiditrite. Question came in. How does ozone therapy
get oxygen to the area of the cancer and cause the cancer to not grow or to thrive?
Good question, but this is not oxygen here. So, this is O2 negative. So, there's actually a missing
little negative sign there. So, this is an O2. I apologize for that. Whoever did this graphic
missed the little negative sign there. And this is ONO, abbreviated ONO, but it's actually called
peroxiditrite. And this is actually a free radical also. So, adding oxygen to your tissue helps
decrease these because it will attach to these two. So, increasing oxygenation of your tissue helps
right here as well. So, if I go out next or size, I'm increasing my oxygenation. It's going to decrease
free radical formation. If I'm going to hyperbaric chamber or I'm going to use ozone,
that could help donate an oxygen and get rid of this. That could help with this. But your body,
so you're doing that exogenous to me, you're trying to add a therapy to help do that.
But normally, within the cell, the superoxide disretais gene is making superoxide disretais to
grab onto superoxide and turn it into hydrogen peroxide and then glutathione and cannelase through
these genes, through these pathways, get rid of hydrogen peroxide, turn it into water, and you pee it
into the toilet. So, this is all about the balance here. Prooxidants and dioxidants. So,
normally, let's say I'm not doing chemotherapy right now, normally, what could cause it increase in
the prooxidants in an increase in cancer? Defects on this pathway. Defects on this pathway
right here. Defects on this pathway. So, we look at these genes to go, oh wow, you don't have any
defects here. You don't have any defects here. No defects here. That's great. So, are there other
reasons why a person would have a lot of prooxidants? Sure, a really crappy diet. So, what we talked about
last week, eating a lot of sugars, causing a lot of excess free radical formation.
Be it around, you know, going and getting radiation, going and getting, okay, should I get x-rays?
Yeah, you could get some x-rays cervical and spinal x-rays, a few x-rays hard going to hurt you,
but if I'm going to get a lot of CT scans, one CT, one abdominal CT scans equivalent to about
50 x-rays. Well, I had four from this last year. That's 200 x-rays. That's going to cause a lot of
free radical damage. It's going to increase the production of free radicals. You better have a
really healthy SOD and glutathione pathways and canelaise pathways to get rid of them.
So, there's different things I'm exposed to pollutants. I'm smoking cigarettes. I'm, you know,
whatever it is that you're exposed to, that increases oxidation, increases reactive oxygen
species, increases oxidative stress. That my antioxidant system here can't keep up with.
Okay, your bored me to death, Dr. Cutters, get to the point. Well, the point is, is when you're doing
chemotherapy, you are purposefully adding oxidants to the body for the whole purpose of causing this
to the cancer cell. I know we have to kill these cancer cells. Let's poison them. Good idea.
How are we going to prevent the other cells from being poisoned? Well, this doctor said we should
take a whole bunch of antioxidants, a whole bunch of things that will help promote this pathway.
Well, should we? No, I don't think so. Maybe 48 hours after you do the chemotherapy, I would do that.
I would not take a whole bunch of antioxidants prior to the chemotherapy. You know, the day before,
the day of, the day after, I would wait at least 48 hours after the chemotherapy because if you're
going to subject your body to chemotherapy, you want this to take place to cancer cells.
If you are going to add antioxidants, you are not only going to protect healthy cells,
you are going to protect cancer cells. So you don't want to hyperlone at antioxidants prior to
chemotherapy. If you're going to take chemotherapy, you want the chemotherapy to work.
Then after 48 hours, then you hyperlone on everything else that we have you going. That's why
follow that sheet that we have that I created as a resource for you for those who are doing chemotherapy
in our blog posts. You guys should be looking at our blog posts. So under our resources page,
there is a blog that I created for, it's a sheet to do if you're doing chemotherapy follow these things.
So it does not say hyperlone at antioxidants, so don't do that.
Because you want the chemotherapy to work. Yes, is it going to cause a crisis of healthy cells?
Yeah, that's the bad thing about chemotherapy. There's nothing you can do about that. But you can stop
the progression of it because chemotherapy is going to kill the cancer cell really within the first
48 hours. After that, we want to load up on antioxidants, detox the body, do your foot pass,
cleanse the body of that chemotherapy so it could decrease the effect on healthy cells. And that's the
whole idea of fasting the day before, the day of the chemotherapy, too, because that gives healthy cells
protection. It does not give the cancer cells protection and that's been proven. Okay.
Board, you guys all the death. Any questions now? I am going to open it up.
Open up your, you know, unmute everybody. Here we go. All right, any questions?
Dr. Connor, so I have one. My cancer was a breast cancer generated by a hormone.
Or anyway, I went through menopause and everything and got rid of all the estrogen. So I'm
periodically experiencing hot flashes. Does that equate to like if you being overexposed to
bad estrogen and the air, air pollution stuff? No, hot flashes are actually a, so, so normally
during the life of a female, her estrogen will be mute everybody while I answer this.
So the majority of your estrogen, I mean, 95% of your estrogen and progesterone is produced by your
ovaries. And then when a woman goes through menopause, the ovaries start to go through normal
program cell death, the function of the ovaries. So you're not producing as much estrogen slowly,
you're producing less and less and less estrogen and progesterone. Now, normally,
if a woman has very healthy adrenal glands, the adrenal glands will make up for that loss of
estrogen and progesterone. They will never produce as much estrogen and progesterone as the ovaries
did. But they'll produce enough so that the woman doesn't have the menopause symptoms.
Everybody on this call has known a woman that's gone through menopause that didn't have any symptoms
at all. And my gosh, I went through menopause. Great. I don't know my parents anymore. Best thing happened
in my life. And it's three other women. They know who are went through menopause. I'm still going
through and I hate it. I have to feel like I want to jump in the freezer sometimes. I feel sick. I don't
feel good. That's the difference between somebody who's got really healthy adrenal glands and somebody
who to the degree and extent of their symptoms has less healthy adrenal glands. Now, I will say if
you did any therapy to produce an early menopause, meaning specific aromatase inhibitors or specific
things that shut down your ovary production in an unnatural way, which everybody with breast cancer
has been at least pushed, that's been pushed on them, that it's almost impossible for your
adrenals to make that up that quickly because it's not a natural process. But it is not abnormal
going through what women have gone through with breast cancer to have those hot flashes and such.
Now, you can use some herbs like Doug Quay and Maka root. We have a product called Estrovite that
literally I've had women say if you stop carrying that, I'm going to kill you. I take that very
serious when a woman tells me that so we make sure we carry that product that saved a lot of women
going through menopause and going through hot flashes and symptoms of menopause. So you can use
products like that that could just help balance your adrenals and help the production of a natural
balance of loss of estrogen and progesterone. Okay, if you could expose to say like,
there you are chemicals and farm chemicals that are going all around, you have an overload of
false estrogens in your body. Could that stimulate yourself to say, hey, there's more here.
Do we develop more sites or do we let it in ourselves? Is it
our body's time to need it because it's saturated with it? Okay, I got to mute everybody in the
lens of that. Is the exposure to exogenous estrogens? Does that stimulate our body to,
if I understand the question correctly, that tell it our body that we need it, does it stimulate
estrogen in our body? Yes, it does. So exogenous estrogens can be a problem and one could argue that
that is a piece of just about every hormonal leader of a cancer. One could argue that all the exogenous
estrogens from, and hormone disruptors from plastics to pesticides, you can't go anywhere without being
exposed to chemicals that are hormone disruptors, and the increase of breast cancer, prostate cancer,
ovarian cancer, and uterine cancer has gone through the rough. Now, that doesn't explain the reason why
other cancers have gone up that aren't hormone driven, but it does, it can, I believe it's nothing
necessarily the primary cause, but it is certainly a contributor to those. And does ongoing exposure
to that cause a problem with somebody who has already went through a bit of pause or, and or,
gone through a process of diminishing their hormones? Of course, it does. That's why you would continue
to use products like DIM to help pull bad estrogens out of your body, because you're going to be exposed
to them, no matter what, by saying with estrogens, you could run, but you can't hide. They're everywhere.
They're a drinking water. They're, you're using plastics, you're using your exposed to pesticides,
your exposed to farmed sprays, it's everywhere. You know, I have one more, I'll leave this alone,
one more question. You don't have me on DIM. Did I not test kneading it because? I don't think you
tested kneading it. So DIM isn't the only product. So the broccoli, the broccoli date,
that those products are really good for that. They roll, but eight are good for that. So there's
other things that help balance the hormones. I don't remember what I'm having one. Dad, I have to look
at it. No, no, that's your question, but okay. Sorry, I'll have to look what to revisit in the chart.
Okay, thank you. Dr. Conner. Go ahead.
Good, Dr. Conner. How often, after 48 hours when you're on chemo, can I do foot bath and should it be
the pro wave frequency one or two or rotator? So I would do foot baths, if I'm doing chemo, I would do
foot bath daily after the 48 hours. Make sure that you are not getting deficient in your minerals.
Make sure you take it in the minerals supplement and then you'll be safe. But I would do them daily.
And I would do some, I'd rotate some of the detox. I would do the cancer program of the pro wave.
I would do like accelerated detox. The detox, the clear-life detox program.
Thank you. Thank you. Dr. Conners. This is pertains to me and I apologize to the rest of the group,
but it doesn't won't let me back on the tractor until you tell me that taking is not,
but not damaging the tumor. You know, with the ground's hard and he just thinks that that might be some of my...
Oh, that's a very good question. So could, and that could be, you could liken that for every tumor. Could
physical vibration cause the tumor to grow? Boy, we could have a game with that one because
you could make an argument both ways. So if there's a lot of bouncing, like it going down a gravel road,
or you're on a tractor bouncing in a field, you think there could be an increase in tissue
disruption and damage, which then an opportunistic disease like cancer is, could give way for more growth.
I could make an argument that way. The way I could make an argument the other way would be,
the way if there's a lot of movement in physical motion, could that cause more lymphatic
motion move it? Yeah, I guess I could make an argument that way. I guess I honestly would fall
on the side of your husband that more physical motion and bouncing at damage would probably do more harm
than good. Okay. Especially if it's, you know, you're not bracing forward in a way like you know,
you're bouncing on a tram, or bouncing on a tram, that's physical motion. Yeah, but you're,
it's consistent, it's smooth, you're, you know, it's a, it's a different motion than bouncing in a car,
hitting bumps and bouncing on a tractor and hitting bumps and that's bringing more aches and stress,
I would say. Okay. I guess I would fall. I mean, I guess I would fall on the side of your husband's
not there. All right. Thank you. Not what I wanted to hear, but thanks. I have a tendency to tell
people that what they want to hear sometimes. I have one more question to ask you actually too.
Michelle suggested that Ion Pro put us, we actually have an eye on me,
ionize me, foot bath, it would not, it's not right, but is that okay? Okay, so good question. So
there's two different types of foot baths out there on the market. The patient just asked this
question this morning. So there's the ionizing foot baths. Those are like the, the ion
cleanse, we have one of those that are office. There's, that's a professional model. I don't know
the model that you have, but those are, those are products that have a metal plate that goes in the
water. You put your feet in the water and it ionizes the water, meaning that it's stimulating the water
to produce positive ions and then negative ions. And you can, you want to run all positive because
your toxin that you know that you have is a negative ion or vice versa. But the one that we have,
we usually have it said at 50 or something like that. So it's running, it's ionizing the water at
positive, that it's ionizing the water at negative. And it will pull out the opposite ion. So the
water is ionized at positive, it's going to pull out negative ions out of your body. And toxins
have a charge to them. So it can pull out that's opposite charged toxin. So that's how that
machine works. The ion pro wave that comes with the rice is not ionizing the water per se. It's
putting frequencies through the water. Now does it help still pull out toxins? Yes it does.
Is it as good as what did the ion pro or the, excuse me, the ion cleanse products, the ionization
products at like pulling out heavy metals? No, I don't think it is. That's where I think that
ion cleanse shines at pulling out heavy metals and pesticides and chemotherapy. But they're the
products are not, they're not inexpensive. So a good ion cleanse can cost you $3,000 for a professional
model. So the ion pro wave I think does a very adequate job. So what you're saying is you have one
of the ion cleanse type products. I would say absolutely use it. They could be better in different
applications. So the ion pro wave shines even more when you're like trying to pull out MST bar,
you're trying to kill lime, you're trying to kill a biotoxin. That's where the ion pro wave from
the rife shines even better. So there they are different tools even though you're sticking your
feet in water and putting the thing in there and running a program and the water might turn
different colors because it's pulling some stuff out of your body. But understand the way it goes
about it is really two completely different physical processes. Why would we ever want to take
ions out? So positive ions don't think of them as positive as they're all positive and they say
nice things to you all day long. They have a positive charge. So ions have the definition of an ion
is it's either has a negative charge or a positive charge. There's a lot of heavy metal toxins that
have a positive charge. So it's not acting that it's that it's still be a free radical. So
that help we're getting a lot of feedback there. What's the risk that we'll be pulling if you're
doing both negative and positive then how do you staff from pulling out good positive and good
negative? Yeah you don't that's the negative that's the bad thing I should say. And what is the good
positive or good negative that you would pull out minerals that's all it is. So you would you will
when you do the ion cleanse you will pull out minerals. But when you sweat you're going to
sweat out minerals too. So it's like okay well make another shot of greens or something or
take a mineral capsule. It's not a big deal. So it's the benefit strongly outweighs the the negative
because all you're losing is that would be the only bad thing. Okay. What is this? Dr. Connors I have
another question. My hands look like I am uncumidant. I have so many really dark purple blotches and
this is me and I'm detoxing too much or the detoxing is working. No I could you take a picture of your
hands and send it to me. Yep. Because that could be there could be a lot of different things. So if your
hands are getting blotchy like you got bruises. No this this just looks like you know someone who has
been uncumidant and like they have those purple spots. Okay so you have purple like like broken
blood vessel type things. I guess it could look like that. I've gotten them on and off before but
just about. I'm getting them they go away in about two days and then they're just a lot bigger.
They're about like oh bigger than a pencil eraser size now. Okay well that could be from a
capillary fragility. So what a person's uncuba did there on a blood did all right. So
then they're blood clotting mechanism isn't as effective. So they bruise really easy. They're
blood vessels. They're small capillaries break quite easily. Normally your small capillaries are
breaking quite easily anyhow but you have enough platelet content and healthy enough blood that you
don't bruise because it seals that capillary up and you don't have any problems with it. But if you're
on a blood thinner than it leaks and you end up with bruises on your hands and on your arms and
such. So that's not a good condition if you're not uncuba did to have that could be low platelet counts.
That's the first thing I would think of. Second thing is, or are you taking tons and tons of
natural blood thinners? Are you on a high dose garlic regimen? Are you on a people that are doing
this vitamin C that could happen too. But I don't think you're doing either one of those two things.
So set me a picture and I'll take a look at it and we'll. Okay. All right. Dr. Kahn. Yes.
I'm just going to ask about therapy and I was wondering if there's been found or that far as far as
far as far as you're just knowing that you're getting rid of it. I don't even know that it's actually
like that. Okay. Can you type that into the chat? Because I'm getting a reverberation from you and I
can can't understand exactly what you're saying. Okay. Okay. I'm going to mute everybody for a second
because we're getting a reverberation of change phone and if you could just mute your phone,
that would be good. Another question came in over the chat while we're doing this. What type of
foot bath is best to do after chemo? Well, that could be disputed too. So the iron foot, the iron
pro wave is the rife one. So the rife foot bath, there could be really good benefits of that.
Running the detox accelerator, excuse me, the detox program with that could be real beneficial.
We've used the iron cleans at our office with that and we've got like after people do chemo,
we've gotten literally it looks like phosphorescent color from the chemo coming out. So
the best scenario to do both if you had a both. But do what you can. If you could get to a
clinic that has an ion, ionizing foot bath, then I would get to a clinic and do that maybe a
couple times a week as well as doing your iron pro wave at home. So there's benefits to both of them.
And Jay, I don't see your, there it is. I just started ozone therapy and I wanted
to know about how it is actually getting to the cancer cells. Okay. So, well, there isn't
any guarantee that it's getting to the cancer cells. So if you're doing ozone therapy, so
ozone is O3. And the benefit of that is that it will freely donate an oxygen to the tissue and it
could donate an oxygen to free radicals O2-negative to to basically get rid of them. And so it acts
as an antioxidant agent. O3 can also attach to bacteria. So it can be really beneficial for those
with lime and those with mold issues. So ozone, I think even shines better with that.
It's, is it getting to the cancer? We don't know that it's getting to the cancer. There's no way to
know that it's getting to the cancer. There are some clinicians that believe in injecting ozone
right into the cancer. We have done that with one of my doctors here that comes, it helps us at the
clinic sometimes who is an emergency ER doctor here with very, very mixed success. So I'm not convinced
that there's benefit to that. Though the quote unquote study we've done has been a pretty
small sample size. So the question ties into the next question that just came across the chat,
which is do you have ZIG shots yet? We have been doing that with ozone with patients and
and separate from ozone with patients. And we again, we don't have a big enough sample size to know
if it is working or not. The success or lack thereof that we've had with patients so far makes me
very discouraged whether that's going to be as beneficial as we hoped, but it's just like with
anything, you know, curcumin is fantastic for cancer patients, but it's really only going to be
fantastic for maybe 20% of cancer patients. So that's where it's difficult. The more people that we have
doing something like that, that gives us some more a bigger sample size in our study whether this
is going to be beneficial or not. So I get to unmute everybody again and we have time for maybe one
more question because I have another appointment in just a couple minutes. Dr. Conor, this is Deb's part.
Those on. What about IVO's on that you can you trip? Yeah, but that still doesn't mean that it's
getting to the cancer. So. And you haven't seen any good. Okay, good enough. Thank you.
Okay, that's Dr. Conor. Yes.
This is the after after 48 hours after chemo, daily put down. Yeah, I would say every 21 day.
Yep, so that I would stop it the day before the chemo again.
When I fast. So the day before your next chemo, I would stop. Good. And then wait for 48 hours after
administration of the chemo. So that's two full days. So you've really stopped for three full days.
The fasting made a huge huge difference. Oh, that's really good news.
Really? I even told that by anyone. Yeah, it was fabulous information. Thank you so much.
Yeah, I know it on colleges too. It tries to do things more natural down in Southern California
who's working with the University of Southern California who's trying to do that with all
their patients. And she just absolutely swears it's makes a difference on everybody by cutting their
symptoms. Yeah, well, that's really good. All right. Well, we're going to have to call it for
today. And we'll get this up on Facebook if you want to listen to it again. Or if you have questions
regarding anything, make sure you get back to me. Bye. Bye everybody. Thank you. You have a great weekend.
Thank you. Thank you.